Trascrizione: Margherita Molettieri
Revisore: Federico Pepe
Mi hanno fornito un assist fantastico questi musicisti!
Oggi 23 febbraio 2014,
per chi non lo sapesse
o magari qualcuno ha già sentito parlare di Leibniz ...
Io sono ossessionato dai numeri.
Amo molto i numeri, in tutte le loro forme.
Ho cercato di immaginarmi un sistema
per memorizzare tanti numeri.
Leibniz, nel 1600-1700, aveva divulgato un sistema
per codificare foneticamente,
per convertire foneticamente i numeri.
E quando ho dovuto immaginarmi
un'apertura per questo mio speech
ovviamente, la prima cosa, la prima attenzione
è stata concentrarmi sui numeri,
cioè cercare di capire
cosa il 23 febbraio 2014 mi voleva dire.
E quello che ne è emerso
è che nel 23 febbraio poteva essere codificato
come: "Un uomo sogna una storia".
Bene, l'avventuriero è un po' un uomo che sogna una storia.
Io nella mia vita ho sognato storie
e continuo a sognare storie.
La musica ci fa sognare delle storie:
eravamo qui ad ascoltare una performance,
ma chissà dove eravamo noi in questo preciso momento!
Talvolta nel mare delle Antille,
talvolta negli anni '60 in qualche pub.
L'essere avventuriero vuol dire proprio
immaginarsi delle cose che ancora non esistono.
E, ovviamente, per farlo in sicurezza
devi anche risolvere dei problemi.
Quindi, se prima c'è il sogno,
dopo dobbiamo cominciare a domandarci
come risolvere i problemi che nascono.
Potremmo anche addirittura dire
che il mio mestiere è quello di cercare i problemi,
non trovare le soluzioni ai problemi.
E, quindi, domandarmi quali generi di combinazioni,
quelle migliaia di combinazioni
in un'avventura si possono verificare
perché, laddove riesco a immaginarmi un problema,
posso anticipare il problema
e, eventualmente, trovare una strategia
per risolvere il problema.
Nella mia vita, come dicevo, ho sognato storie,
ho sognato di attraversare le montagne,
i continenti in mongolfiera.
Ho sognato di andare in Antartide,
di andare al Polo Nord.
Nessuna di queste tre cose però si è mai realizzata.
Un giorno ho sognato
di attraversare un oceano a remi.
E alla fine l'ho fatto per due volte.
Quindi mi sono domandato a un certo punto
che cosa e perché, dei tanti sogni che l'essere umano fa,
sono pochi quelli che si realizzano.
E non sono dell'idea
che il problema o la differenza stia nella forza
con cui uno sogna.
Allora sono giunto alla conclusione
che alla vita non gliene frega niente dei nostri sogni.
La vita, alla fine, ci porta laddove è meglio per noi.
E, quindi, ho smesso anche di meravigliarmi
di tutte quelle situazioni, piccole e grandi, paradossali,
che ho vissuto
perché sta all'interno di un disegno,
un disegno dove io c'entro poco,
io sono l'attore di un film
e vivo la mia vita nel tentativo
di renderla anche, talvolta, divertente
e, laddove possibile, anche emozionante.
Nel 2004 ho voluto buttarmi in un'avventura
che sembrava, agli occhi delle persone, impossibile.
Per chi non lo sapesse, io sono valtellinese,
sono nato in montagna, in Valtellina.
Il giorno in cui, ed era notte, ed era inverno,
c'era anche la neve,
giunsi in Aprica con la mia barca a remi,
la gente non sapeva neanche
che cosa fosse una barca a remi.
Neanche da quale fosse la prua e quale fosse la poppa.
Quindi, ho dovuto immaginarmi
come rendere qualcosa di impossibile
in qualche cosa di possibile.
Trovare le soluzioni, andare ad esplorare le varie possibilità,
perché se c'è qualcosa di impossibile,
forse non è che è impossibile il progetto,
forse è impossibile o è difficile o è sbagliato, meglio dire,
la strategia con cui ci approcciamo al progetto.
Quindi, il 2004, era il 10 ottobre del 2004,
partii da Genova nel tentativo, nel mio primo tentativo,
di attraversare l'Oceano Atlantico in barca a remi.
Se voi fosse stati presenti nel molo di partenza,
da dove partii quel giorno,
forse anche voi avreste pensato
che quello fosse una cosa impossibile da fare.
Non ero mai salito su una barca a remi prima,
non sapevo come tenere in mano dei remi,
non sapevo neanche
di che cosa dovessi avere paura in quel momento.
Per giusto darvi una sensazione
della poca fiducia che davo alle persone,
mio padre, che mi salutava dal molo,
mi salutava come se quella fosse l'ultima volta
a vedermi vivo.
Io oggi ho due figlie: una di 4 e una di 2 anni.
Vivo con il ricordo di un padre
che mi lasciava sperimentare,
mi lasciava anche cadere.
Oggi la tentazione di mettere una manina sotto
laddove cadrà la testa di mia figlia è troppo forte.
E' solo che, nel cercare di alleviare lei di qualche dolore,
forse impedisco a lei di imparare delle cose
che potranno servirle
laddove, un giorno, non ci sarà più la mano di un padre
ad attutire il colpo.
Bene, quel giorno lì, se, come dicevo,
se foste stati presenti,
avreste creduto che la cosa era impossibile.
A ben vedere!
Perché, sei ore dopo, sono costretto a tornare in porto.
Ero partito come un eroe dei due mondi,
e, dopo sei ore, avevo già visto l'altra faccia della medaglia;
cioé quanto è facile partire da eroe,
e poi finire per farsi sputtanare pubblicamente,
perché, dopo sei ore, come dicevo,
fui costretto a tornare in porto.
Ma prima di tornare in porto ho detto:
"Qua bisogna lanciare un grido di emergenza!"
E ho contattato la capitaneria di porto, chiedendo assistenza,
volevo che loro mi portassero fuori
da queste 10 miglia costiere
perché, pensavo io,
mi avrebbero garantito una navigazione notturna sicura.
Dall'altra parte della radio mi dissero:
"Noi le vite le mettiamo al sicuro, non le mettiamo in pericolo!"
Ho detto: "Ah però, avete ragione in questo senso!"
Quindi negoziammo questo affare,
mi vengono a prendere e vengo riportato in porto.
Undici giorni dopo, però, decido di ripartire,
perché, forse, non è impossibile l'obiettivo,
è semplicemente sbagliata la strategia.
Quel giorno lì era, undici giorni dopo,
al pontile c'erano quattro persone.
Ho detto: "Adesso, ok, ho fatto la cosa in grande,
questa volta invece aspettiamo
di uscire dalle 10 miglia costiere.
Partii, feci 23 giorni di navigazione,
navigai per 1000 km, superai il Golfo del Leone,
che, per chi è stato nel Golfo del Leone tra i presenti in sala
saprà che è un po' un mare terribile,
e, anzi, ho incontrato più cattivo tempo nel Mediterraneo,
di quanto non ne abbia incontrato nell'Atlantico.
Quindi non sono le misure a far la differenza.
Dopo 23 giorni mi sentivo ormai proiettato,
bastava solo qualche tempo ancora, qualche mese,
proiettato verso la mia destinazione finale: il Brasile.
Peccato che le condizioni e la vita fu differente
da quella che mi immaginavo.
Dopo 23 giorni, una notte di tempesta,
subisco un black-out ai pannelli solari
che mi costringono a fare i conti con l'incertezza,
non sapevo più dove stavo andando.
Vedevo in lontananza delle luci
che per me poteva essere qualunque genere di isola.
Nei momenti in cui ero affossato tra le onde,
perdevo di vista anche queste.
La mattina, alle 11 della mattina del 23° giorno,
sono troppo vicino alla costa
e, quindi, aspetto il momento migliore
per abbandonare la barca.
Non ho tempo per pensare
perché la barca subisce un capovolgimento
e io vengo buttato in acqua
e guadagno terra a nuoto.
La barca rimane ferma per qualche secondo
ancorata all'ancora
e io comincio, alla disperata ricerca di qualcuno,
inizio a correre.
Peccato che era novembre,
e qualcuno di voi sicuramente è già stato a Fortaleza.
La prima persona che incontro a Fortaleza mi dice:
"Tu sei il primo italiano che viene a Fortaleza d'inverno!"
Dico: "Ah ok! La prossima volta anticipo,
grazie della dritta!"
Fatto sta che giro, sono anche un po' miope,
quindi nell'impatto avevo perso una scarpa,
avevo perso le lenti a contatto,
ero emerso dal mare come un mostro marino,
quindi, la faccia, l'impressione che davo
non era proprio della persona, insomma, che ispira fiducia.
Dopo due ore incontro una coppia di persone
che guardano romanticamente il mare.
E allora io le sorprendo facendo un giro da dietro
e appoggio le mie mani sul cofano
e dico: "Aiutooo!!
Sono un navigatore!
Sono solitario!
Vengo dall'Italia! Sono su una barca a remi!
Sono naufragato!"
Forse potevo evitare qualche dettaglio!
perché le persone non mi hanno...
questa signora me la ricordo con gli occhi così!
Grossi come due arance. Non mi aveva subito creduto.
Ho impiegato qualche secondo, qualche minuto per la verità,
prima che loro decidessero
di almeno abbassare un pochettino il finestrino
e ascoltare quello che avessi da dire.
Io, quindi, organizzati i soccorsi, mi appresto
per arrivare al sito dove ero naufragato qualche ora prima.
E quello che trovo è un'immagine di questo genere qua:
desolazione.
Un sogno, siccome siamo partiti parlando di sogni,
un sogno che si era infranto contro degli scogli,
che, nuovamente, per chi è stato a Formentera,
sa che ci sono solo 250 metri lineari di scogli
perché tutto il resto è spiaggia.
Ecco, la vita mi aveva portato là,
esattamente dove, oggi valuto,
dove era meglio per me in quel momento.
Il mare mi ha insegnato
che ci sono delle cose che puoi controllare
e cose che non puoi controllare.
E la cosa che puoi controllare è il processo,
quello che ti porta a fare le cose,
non tanto il risultato finale.
Quindi partii, lasciai l'isola con quello che adesso mi fa ridere
perché mi avevano considerato Robinson in Formentera.
Però, se prestiamo un po' di attenzione,
in cima alla pagina c'era già scritto qualcosa
che aveva un tutt'altro sapore.
Allora, io sento:
"Ma io posso decidere che cosa fare in questo momento,
se prendere questo momento come un 2 a 0,
un K.O. definitivo,
oppure vederci del buono,
vederci, scorgere, setacciare, scorgere il seme
che mi avrebbe, un giorno, potuto permettere
di arrivare dall'altra parte.
La prima telefonata che ricevo,
quando sono in ospedale,
è quella di mio padre.
L'avevo lasciato che mi salutava a mai più da Genova,
e al telefono mi disse:
"Torna a casa che ricostruiamo un'altra barca."
Alla fine l'entusiasmo aveva generato coinvolgimento,
le persone si erano accorte
che forse quello che stavo facendo,
sì, agli occhi di qualcuno,
poteva essere il grido disperato di uno scappato di casa,
di un matto,
dall'altra parte c'era qualcosa
che, se al terzo tentativo,
un uomo vuole ancora volontariamente mettersi in gioco,
mettersi lì nelle condizioni di venire criticato, sbeffeggiato,
ridicolizzato, preso come un montanaro,
perché appunto l'origine è montanara,
allora forse dovevano prestare un po' più di attenzione.
Quindi riparto, nel 2005 riparto,
era una giornata straordinaria in quella situazione lì,
supero l'isola di Formentera,
supero il Golfo del Leone,
e laddove, un anno prima, avevo trovato un'isola,
su cui ero naufragato,
in quell'anno lì, invece, raccolsi da terra 30 kg di droga.
In realtà, la raccolsi dal mare, 30 kg di droga.
Qualcuno adesso, lo so, perché poi funziona così,
si dirà: "Ah! Ecco come ha fatto
ad attraversare un oceano a remi!"
Ma io sono preparato e mi ero preparato a questo!
Ho detto: no!
Ho voluto documentare
perché, se fossi venuto qua senza documenti fotografici,
nessuno mi avrebbe creduto.
In quel momento lì mi sono domandato:
"Cosa posso fare adesso?
Perché qui la mia missione è un'altra.
Non è di fare il trafficante di droga,
bensì di attraversare un oceano a remi."
E, quindi, buttai via tutti i pezzettini, fino all'ultimo,
ho detto: "Questo lo devo tenere però
perché altrimenti i miei amici, quando tornerò a casa,
non crederanno a quello che sto dicendo."
Fortuna vuole che buttai anche l'ultimo pezzettino.
E dico fortuna vuole perché 40 giorni dopo
venni arrestato a Tangeri,
nel tentativo di attraversare Gibilterra,
perché credevano che fossi un corriere della droga.
Ed erano marocchini, ed erano decisi,
ed erano anche ben seri.
Dicevo: "Scusatemi, sono su una barca a remi,
è sponsorizzata, è arancione. Quindi..
Dice: "Eh, ma qua i camuffamenti sono i più imprevedibili,
quindi non ci stupirebbe che tu possedessi della droga.
Ho impiegato 4 giorni prima di contrattare
con una persona venuta da Casablanca, il governatore,
in realtà era un console italiano,
il quale mi aiutò per farmi restituire il passaporto.
Quindi la mia navigazione riprende,
supero le Colonne d'Ercole,
queste Colonne che rappresentavano
quello che era stato prima tutto l'allenamento.
Dopo quattro mesi ero pronto
per attraversare un oceano a remi.
Ma ho detto: "Ma io sono stanco morto!
Come faccio adesso a passare
i prossimi 5 mesi di navigazione?
Bella domanda!
Soprattutto perché il cibo iniziava a scarseggiare
e io mi stavo buttando in un mare
dove probabilmente non avrei visto anima viva
per il resto dei miei giorni fino a Fortaleza.
180 giorni dopo la partenza rimango senza cibo.
Rimango senza cibo e le cause sono molto varie.
Durante i capovolgimenti la barca prendeva acqua,
il cibo veniva intaccato dall'acqua,
il cibo marciva e quindi lo buttavo via.
Dall'altra parte ero molto stressato, ero molto affaticato,
volevo tanto tornare a casa, avevo nostalgia
e tutte quelle cose da cui volevo scappare,
cioè scappare! però volevo allontanarmi un pochettino.
Quindi scoprire quanto, invece, sia fatto di una carne,
molto simile alle persone qui dentro in sala,
e quindi dopo 180 giorni rimango senza cibo.
Col team di supporto riusciamo, in un primo momento,
a farmi recapitare del cibo da una nave di passaggio,
una nave norvegese,
che mi scarica a bordo 180 kg di cibo.
E dite: "Beh, insomma, cibo sufficiente per un'intera navigazione."
Bastarono solo 18 giorni per finire quelle scorte di cibo.
Erano completamente saltati gli schemi.
E quindi nella seconda telefonata
che feci al mio team di supporto,
loro mi dissero: "Adesso il miracolo lo devi fare tu.
Adesso devi immaginarti tu una maniera per arrivare a terra.
La vita ti sta dando un'altra occasione,
l'occasione si chiama Arcipelago di San Pedro e San Paolo,
in mezzo all'Oceano Atlantico,
mancano 60 miglia,
sei a sole 60 miglia da un'isola
che potrebbe definire la tua vita
o, in un altro caso, un momento un pochettino più tragico."
E quindi ricordo quei 5 giorni
come i giorni più intensi della mia vita.
Giorni in cui pregai,
giorni in cui feci le sedute spiritiche
invocando gli spiriti di Fogar, di Shackleton,
di tutti i più grandi navigatori che questo mondo ha visto.
Avevo bisogno di aiuto,
avevo bisogno di credere
che qualcuno potesse portarmi fuori da lì,
avevo bisogno di sentirmi capace
di tollerare quella situazione.
E, quindi, giunsi, dopo 5 giorni di totale digiuno,
su questo arcipelago,
dove gli scienziati che vivevano sull'isola,
i primi ad approcciarmi,
credevano che fossi un naufrago,
e la prima regola per aiutare un naufrago
è non dar da mangiare al naufrago.
Arrivai poi a Fortaleza,
dove lì c'era mio padre,
quello con le gambe color mozzarella è mio padre.
In quel momento si chiudeva un sogno.
Il sogno, ricorre spesso in questa storia il sogno,
perché io credo di essere fortemente legato ai sogni,
io sono guidato dai sogni,
però come genere umano
e come esemplare del genere umano,
sono anche legato alle ipotesi,
sono anche le ipotesi che mi governano.
E le ipotesi sono le credenze,
sono gli status quo,
sono tutte quelle cose che diamo per scontato.
Solo nel momento in cui siamo in grado
di esplorare oltre queste ipotesi,
mettendo in dubbio anche le credenze,
quello che le persone credono che sia dato per scontato.
Il "Si è sempre fatto così" riduce del 50% le possibilità
di fare qualcosa di straordinario.
Possiamo, per esempio,
continuare a vedere di queste immagini
quello che crediamo che qualcuno ci voglia fare intendere,
quindi due pezzi di albero.
E, invece, se esploriamo un pochettino più in là,
potremmo scoprire che le opportunità
di vederci altre cose sono molto differenti.
Sono passati ormai 10 anni
da quel giorno in cui naufragai a Formentera,
e oggi lo ricordo, come avevamo detto prima,
come uno di quei momenti da cui non si può scappare.
Questo è un pezzo di barca che rimane di quel giorno lì.
L'ho portato a casa perché questo mi insegna
che impossibile non è per sempre.
Impossibile non è per sempre
e forse lo è davvero.
Forse quello che dobbiamo dare a noi stessi
è solo un'altra opportunità
perché le opportunità, dopo tutto, sono le cose
che più hanno valore nell'economia generale di un uomo.
E oggi guardo in prospettiva a questo pezzo di legno
e penso: "Pensa se non ci avessi riprovato.
Pensa che differente la mia vita sarebbe
se non ci avessi riprovato,
se non avessi rimesso piede su quella barca
e avessi continuato a sognare."
Oggi forse sarei una persona meno felice.
Grazie.